know your place be a shoe snowpiercer
again well I don't do straightforward
movie reviews on here largely just
because I rarely get to see stuff when
it first comes out but this one I do
want to talk about because it only had a
limited release and it's not going to be
available to see on disk until the end
of October and I want to get my thoughts
in before that happens now this is the
english-language debut of korean
director bong joon-ho who I know is the
director of the host no no no no no not
that one god no the other one the go yes
that one the monster one who so
snowpiercer set in the future and is
dealing with a post-apocalyptic scenario
where in an attempt to try and reverse
global warming humans inadvertently set
off a new ice age not just a regular ice
age like a mega ice age everything is
dead the only survivors are the
occupants of this train it's in
perpetual motion around the globe and
it's divided very rigidly by class the
most wretched people are stuck in the
back of the train and the people in
front and control obviously living a
much nicer life now the people stuck in
the back they have been putting up with
it for years and after years of
maltreatment they are ready to storm the
train take control of the engine this is
the kind of big concept sci-fi that
really doesn't get made all that much
anymore I think part of the problem with
studios tend to fear that audiences will
start poking holes in the basic premise
right off the bat but if you're doing
that you're questioning the logical or
scientific viability of the opening
premise of the film then you've missed
the point because the point is not the
train and the Ice Age these are just
concepts being used to explore bigger
questions of things like class warfare
societal obligation and human nature
these sorts of movies really have their
heyday in the 60s and 70s when sci-fi
concepts were used to explore social
situations before Star Wars came along
and every sci-fi movie since then has
just been about giving us explosions in
space
news and really whether or not you can
set that expectation aside is going to
be the key to whether or not you're
going to enjoy this film because having
been raised by and trained by American
movies there is a point about midway
through this movie that it takes a shift
and if you can't get your head out of
the American blockbuster mentality the
movie might well lose you because right
at the point where if this was an
American movie with an American director
made by an American studio the point at
which the thing would just step on the
gas and go full throttle to the climax
is exactly where it slows down and it
does that deliberately it does it with a
purpose to make sure you're paying
attention and you've got to be able to
make that gear shift with the movie so
that you can take in what it's doing
otherwise you're going to be sitting
there checking your watch waiting for
the next action scene now don't get me
wrong there are more action scenes later
on and they're really good they're well
constructed their great set pieces but
the action is not the point and the
movie is not going to let you get away
with sitting through it just to watch
the action scene if you can make that
shift there is a lot to enjoying soaked
in about this movie aside from just the
big concepts that it deals with them
dealing with them very interestingly and
very well it also offers something that
we so rarely see any more genuine cast
diversity okay yeah sure we've got
captain america chris evans in the lead
he does fantastic work for the record
though but we've also got front and
center main characters this korean
father and daughter who are speaking
Korean for most of the movie you've got
Octavia Spencer right up there and even
amongst the rest of the white guys we've
got diversity in terms of Jamie Bell
we've got John Hurt we've got Luke
Pasqualino you know there's this mix of
ethnicities and ages and agendas I mean
it's both refreshing unto itself it
helps with the notion of this really is
just a microcosm for the world and some
of the points that the film is trying to
make it helps make them all the better
as good as all those cast members who
have already talked about our though the
standout is Tilda Swinton she plays a
sort of middle management type and she
is she's almost impossible to describe
she is bizarre and over-the-top in a way
like is she do is this a joke is she a
caricature but there's actually a lot of
done a lot of layers me to give you an
idea of how ridiculous this woman is her
first big speech directed at the
occupants of the back of the Train she
compares them to a shoe and says that
their desire to move further up in the
cars and the train it's like putting a
shoe on your head I mean it's ridiculous
and it should break the movie but the
more you see her the more you sort of
see slightly behind this this facade of
insanity that's up there and you get the
depths of what she's I mean she she was
mesmerizing every second she was on the
screen if there's one complaint I might
have about this movie it might be that
it's trying to tackle a few too many
ideas there's some stuff that's just
kind of tacked on there with ideas about
indoctrination there's a little bit in
there about drug addiction that they
feel a little bit tacked on but
thankfully that not in a way that's
distracting they are there it doesn't
delve too much into them but they don't
distract from the main points that the
thing is making about human nature and
the role of authority and its bigger
concepts and the fact that these are
just kind of there but not delved into
overly actually kind of helps sell the
idea that this train is the world
trapped in a bottle and it brings all
the problems as i said the action scenes
are really good but and like I mentioned
you got to be sure that you can get out
of the normal blockbuster mindset
because this is not a standard
blockbuster it's got some blockbuster
beats and it's got some really
well-executed stuff if you go in there
wanting good actually you're going to
get good action but if that's all you're
going in for you are going to come away
confused and disappointed probably a
little annoyed but if you can just go
and be willing to travel to where this
movie wants to take you you're not going
to regret seeing it whether you agree
with the side that it takes on some of
these points or not it's just really
fascinating to see a movie this well
executed and dealing with these kinds of
questions now like I said this sort of
movie had its heyday back in the 60s and
70s so out of those sorts of
high-concept sci-fi films that tackle
social issues what was your favorite of
this kind of movie I'm talking about
things like Soylent Green silent running
Logan's Run the original Planet of the
Apes those sorts of films what
your personal favor whatever it is drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it until next time this
council is adjourned